Norman up against the network against
for the sake of comedy Seth Meyers is
the network he's a producer he's the one
telling people what they can and can't
say I was gonna do everything wrong with
Seth Meyers
another question today who do you think
is definitively the worst of the
late-night chain gang you've got Kimmel
Colbert Noah B Myers am I missing any
Fallon if Allen he's kind of
inconsequential the main theme here is
that with Seth Meyers
he's a picture perfect example of
someone who places politics over comedy
and he's been bolstered by a big network
because of it in spite of the fact that
he's not very popular or well-liked
that's what bothers mean I think it's a
big thing well we talked about the the
Correspondents Dinner
this is a constant thing but I think
Seth Meyers is one of the worst
offenders and the reason I brought it up
is because it is trending and every
single YouTube feed it's related to all
of my videos for some reason so alright
let's go let's go all both barrels right
now okay so his political history before
it is really well known as far as
actively endorsing or performing with
Democratic politicians or giving large
sums of cash okay let's start with that
and then you have of course like
Samantha B with Schneiderman or Seth
Meyers with Snyderman you have him
swooning over any DNC politician on his
show as though they're a rock star
exhibit Donald Trump does not like
either of us but he might dislike you
more because I tell jokes about him but
you sue him and sometimes did you get
into the race thinking well obviously
I'll be the young hip choice dominate
there that you're here I want to
congratulate you on a birthday Planned
Parenthood just turned a hundred years
old
exactly October that's a grand jury
investigation into alleged wrongdoing by
Planned Parenthood has produced a
surprising indictment so the Republican
candidates made this into a national
political scandal the tapes prompted a
series of investigations
even as Planned Parenthood and most
independent fact checkers insisted the
tapes were deceptive he's a barrel of
laughs and NBC as well as a long history
of ties the DNC in the Clintons
questionable at best here's something
else when you look at executives when
they push Seth Meyers this is the kind
of that really really grinds my gears
they push them because of
political agenda like you look at NBC
chairman with Bob Bob Greenblatt I think
he was pushing Myers as the anti-trump
poster oh he's a he's a voice right now
in a time of darkness Seth Meyers is
needed you don't see executives saying
he's just a funniest guy for the job
it's like you really think Seth Meyers
is funny
he's necessary I mean in general he's
just praised for his antitrump material
that's what that's again when you're
talking about late-night comedy shows
you look back at Carson even you look
back at early Letterman you even look
back at early Conan before turning to
even look even look at Jon Stewart
here's the thing before we got to this
current crop Jon Stewart made sense he
was really the first sort of cable
late-night host
yet at that point there were really only
two and Fox News Post Iraq war was
surging so it was it was an antidote to
this sort of Fox News cable channel that
was dominating and it was it made sense
he was questioned and by the way you
don't see the same vitriolic hatred from
Jon Stewart that you see from today's
laughs yeah plus he was funny
so his average late-night viewership is
somewhere around 1 million which is
significantly less than some big
podcasts or online shows that you might
watch so um for YouTube video and this
is again we're contrasting the praise
and the push that he gets versus the
results and of course putting agenda
over comedy which is which is the
problem but I think people that for
YouTube is video views usually stay in
the tens of thousands on average okay if
you look at the last two day for the
time of this video all of his videos are
below 50,000 plays I think senator you
did some some math right yeah for the
last two shows they did okay it came out
as a little at not 50,000 on average for
videos that are not political using
50,000 plays an average except for
antitrump videos it's the only time as
soon as he attacks anything Trump
related the leftist media promotes it
like the gaggle they are and his news
get into the millions save a discrepancy
of tens of thousands if he's lucky for
comedy which one could argue as the
original purpose of a late-night program
versus millions when he attacks Trump
why because it makes it into the
trending list I can argue a formula one
could argue almost a formula and this is
white numbers and comedy overall are
down from what they used to be I mean
think about this for a second when was
the last time Seth Meyers or Trevor Noah
or Samantha bee came out with a joke
that had some sting on it where people
went what Oh Jeff Miley did that Wow
for him that's the purpose of comedy I
could perfect that by side comparison
take Seth Meyers why can you a lot of
people go I just can't stand up I don't
know why he bothers me so much
take Seth Meyers weekend update' let's
compare him with weekend update' one of
the best Weekend Update hosts ever in
nor McDonald now Norma Connell was fired
by an executive Don Don ohlmeyer back
then at NBC for making fun of Michael
Jackson and OJ Simpson let's roll some
clips while in the hospital Michael
Jackson had his room specially decorated
with two huge photos of Shirley Temple
but don't get the wrong idea here
Michael Jackson is a homosexual
pedophile King of Pop Michael Jackson
who collapsed during rehearsals for a
concert last week without has been
released from the hospital he gobbles
the nails condition is stable and
continues to improve although he is
still a freak first you cannot find a
good version of that clip anyone who was
alive at that time can tell you that
that was that clip on the audit heard
around the world that was why he was
fired you can find clips of Nohr
McDonald a lot older than that you can
find clips of no-name comedians during
the oj trial you cannot find a better
quality clip than that on youtube right
now how insane is that he got fired for
that they said don't make any more jokes
about Michael don't make any more jokes
about oj have to understand during that
time this was post Rodney King the oj
thing kind of took on a black lives
matter yeah tone for that time even
though everyone knew he was guilty right
it was there was o happen to be a racist
cop on the force grant you that racist
okay alright so no one gun was fired for
that and as a comedian what do you do he
fired right back yeah I think I'm funny
in Weekend Update and god only knows I
mean you know he it's just a matter of
opinion he also thinks that oj is
innocent there you go norm went up
against the network against for the sake
of comedy Seth Meyers is the network
he's a producer he's the one telling
people what they can and can't say and I
know listen this is a bias this might be
a blindside people say it because I see
this on both the left and the right yeah
I absolutely do think that the left is
worse for comedy because people on the
right are not trying to police what you
can say Nick DiPaolo Joe Rogan Jim Noor
we talked about these people Owen
Benjamin they are not trying to tell you
what you can or cannot say even if
they're saying hey doesn't comedy
sucking up because it's so far
left-leaning and I get the left of
saying alright letting comedy sucks but
there's only one side trying to tell you
what you can and can't say and that's
Seth - Seth Meyers
what's constructed almost in an unfunny
laboratory ok let's go let's go down the
list being a political pawn cause number
one product sales coming second network
loyalty coming third and then it could
be argued maybe on a good day comedy
coming in fourth on the list and when
you contrast that with comedy of your
and comedians of your like nor
McDonald's well I think Norman self said
it best you know if you really want to
be really funny then that's that's what
you want to do you want to think what
would make Seth Meyers laugh that's how
I live my life hey there YouTube viewer
if you like this video I would say
subscribe hit the notification bell or
watch one of these videos playing in a
box that we've personally uploaded in
program for your viewing pleasure the
problem is now in today's day and age on
YouTube in 2018 any of those three
things that you do any of those three
buttons that you click will take you
directly to a Seth Meyers video so stay
here and join my get off of here go to a
little credit account slash buckle up
it's the only safe place you can go
enjoy